some 1.3 million news or wildebeests
live in the Serengeti every other year
Felix Bordner and Robert Muir from the
frankfurt zoological society conduct an
aerial census they count a sample of
animals and then use that figure to
calculate how many there are in the
greater area
the wildebeest census is one of the most
important ones we do in the Serengeti
because everything in this ecosystem is
connected with these animals if there
are fewer wildebeest there will be fewer
predators the newest begin their great
migration at the end of the dry season
the animals traverse thousands of
kilometers of savanna in search of food
news are extremely good at finding water
so there are good bellwether of the
state of the ecosystem and possible
climate change the rainy seasons here
are getting drier and the dry seasons
wetter that affects the quality of the
grass which is the news main source of
food
if rainfall patterns change and that
rainfall gradient shifts a hundred
kilometers north of the Serengeti it
would be catastrophic for the wildebeest
they would be migrating out of the
Serengeti and into village land where
there is no no grass for them the
frankfurt zoological society has made
protecting the serengeti its main
priority park employees provide advice
and assistance the biggest immediate
challenge that we're facing instead of
poaching for for ivory and for rhino
horn there is a poaching wave sweeping
across Africa currently and the
Serengeti is not immune and is losing
elephants from from the ecosystem
Rangers patrol nearly 24 hours a day to
ward off poachers still some 150,000
animals a year fall victim to illegal
hunting poaching is a real problem in
the Serengeti
I mean poachers do look for game meat
they also look for rhino horns and
elephant tusks the frankfurt zoological
society has been fighting to protect
animal species for more than half a
century it's an ongoing battle
Dinka thus where I think it would be a
tragedy if the Serengeti ceased to exist
if we were to lose this place it will be
hard to justify to future generations
nation getting a tussle